the former head of NFL reps and rules
analyst for Fox back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you sir you know
what's always been great to be in the
Rich Eisen show it's always been great
to get a potential rule change from you
all of that stuff so it's fantastic
makes my Mondays Wow as you know Mike I
was talking about I thought that the
catch rule was handled we haven't really
had too many of those problems now my
windmill I am tilting at is the the
roughing the passer rule and it seems
like whatever was discussed last
Wednesday even though they did not
change the language and they did not
change the emphasis they changed
something because I didn't see a lot of
the non stop flags on the front the
flags I saw on those penalties where
we're mostly merited except for I think
Arden key breathed on Baker Mayfield in
one right what do you what are you
hearing of what was what was went down
in that conversation lastly I think if
you you know this there was no rule
change we understand that but if you
look at language that came out of that
they they said some things that to me
were reminiscent of what they did with
the initiating contact with the helmet
when they came out and said it's not a
foul if it's incidental or inadvertent
and as soon as they said that boom it
disappeared off the face of the earth
because it gave officials latitude to
not call those iffy ones and when they
said in after this conference call that
they didn't change the rules but they
talked about techniques and it's those
techniques that made the difference the
technique of putting your arm down to
brace yourself when you hit the ground
the technique of attempting to get to
the side when you're landing on top of
the quarterback and and that's what has
led to the change and I just looked at a
whole series of plays where where
players did a good job when they were
got when they were put in that situation
of coming up from the middle and
wrapping up kind of like Clay Matthews
did they did a good job of extending
their arms going to the ground to try to
brace their falls and they weren't
called roughing the passer when they
were prior to this so there was really
only one and it was CJ Beathard of the
40
got driven into the ground and literally
the defender there wrapped him up and
took him slammed them into the ground
and never extended his arms and that's
what's called and that's the only one
and I think that's the way that it
should be and so hopefully we're gonna
be through with this and not have to
talk about this and we'll get a catch no
catch controversy that's gonna bring a
small back to normal steel we'll start
talking about what it catches though
Mike I think that's fixed I've you do i
do where we've got one game left in week
four everything that I've seen and I
seen even ones where I knew for a fact
last year it would have been reversed or
non touchdown or whatever and they just
leave it alone I hope you're right I
know that we saw one that we felt would
have been reversed but their philosophy
this was a which one this is really a I
don't remember which team it was but it
was it because it wasn't one of our
games but it was a catch and on the
field they ruled the ball ruled that the
receiver had the ball long enough but
but he didn't but they stayed with it
talking about a holiday on Sunday Night
Football creasing the endzone against
the New England Patriots no no no no
that wasn't the one but I wish I had a
better memory to remember what but I
just kind of glanced at it that we
thought it would have been incomplete
but they left it as it was because he
got control got both feet down and the
officials on the field ruled that he
kept it long enough and they stayed with
it so they're doing that which I think
you know brings in common sense and
stays with what the officials call is so
I I hope that's the case and like you
say we're one game away from being
completed in week four and and and I
don't know what we're gonna talk about
if in fact us roughing the passer thing
goes away well as long as there's the
Cleveland Browns versus Oakland Raider
touchdown so they'll be lots to discuss
Mike Pereira what do you say to Browns
fans this morning based on what was what
happened yesterday
well you know I struggled overnight with
this um you know because from our
studios we kind of pretty strongly said
that it shouldn't have been reversed but
when I went back and looked at this
morning again and we're talking about
the measurement that took the first down
away
yes made it shortened force the punt
when it when essentially if it would
have stayed a first down they could have
run out the clock I think you short I
mean I look at the live shot the line
feed as we call it and in some ways you
have to piece it together but you know
the first thing that hits is the form
and elbow and to me he's not at the 19
yard line where he needs to get and so
even though I went on I went on the air
in Cleveland today and talked about how
I didn't feel there was enough to
overturn it and you know we were talking
about angles you know or deans talk
about angles with this angle you know it
make distorts of you but it's the line
feet of snow angle it's shot right down
the line and I think I would say to
Cleveland although you got burned on a
fumble call where they rule the
quarterback was in the grasp and that
was not a good call Baker Mayfield was
hit in the head and the end of the game
that wasn't called and should have been
called but when it comes to the to the
measurement thing I mean I think New
York got it right well I mean let's
let's just take it one at a time here I
mean I I couldn't tell anything that was
clear and obvious to overturn a first
down call Mike you see you're saying if
you were here with me right now
yes I got to show you the video frame by
frame I think I could convince you and I
think I can convince you fairly okay so
then let's let's place that one aside
the in the grasp call if we as Chiefs
fans will always mention flashes playoff
game right and then this call from
yesterday why can't replay say okay it
was blown dead but it's so obvious that
the ball came out and it was obvious
that the ball came out on the other side
of humanity that Walt Andersen couldn't
see it why can't they give the ball to
Cleveland after it was a clear recovery
by Cleveland when that well came out and
just wipe away the return I think you
maybe this is your eyes and point for
this year if they rule in the grasp and
if you have actual clear and obvious
video that the ball is out before he's
even in the grasp
which was the case maybe you ought to be
able to review that I could I could get
behind that now if he's being wrapped up
by somebody and and then the ball comes
out no matter how quick it is then
that's a different story but in this
case in this case I mean there was not
progress was ruled it was in the grasp
and nobody had him in the grasp and the
ball was out and I think I think I
actually although I'm not a proponent of
adding place to instant replay I think
that might be one I would consider
consider adding if in fact the ball is
out before the quarterback is actually
in anybody's grasp and maybe replay
could turn it over and if there is the
recovery and the immediate action I'm
after the play then give the ball to the
defense I support that action okay Mike
so what do we do with this now so then
this kind of beat look it you mean you
get the Tuck play done you got yeah you
got the catch thing check that box this
this this maybe maybe isn't well it's
big and this particular is maybe it's
not as tough but I was huge in last
year's toss Mike no I know but and I I
agree now I'm not I mean that one was
even a ruling of forward progress which
there was no maybe if the balls out
before there's any forward progress and
I think I you know it becomes a yeah I
kind of agree it becomes a bit of a
cop-out it's be a you know if you're on
the field you could just say hey I'm
gonna rule forward progress and then it
can't be reviewed um I'm
I think I'm jumping into your bandwagon
okay all right so we're gonna do that
what else am I missing before I let you
go Mike that you think the first four
weeks we're not discussing or the NFL
front office is discussing that hasn't
reached top of mind yet because that
hasn't affected a win-loss or a major
first down well I'll tell you what's
interesting to me is we all talked about
the new four new referees and the
adjustments that they're gonna have to
make and and how it's going to be
difficult for them but the problems were
discussing there with the veterans
they're not with the new guys and and I
find that kind of fascinating that the
the youngsters so to speak have seemed
to develop really pretty quickly and so
you know I'm still looking at the game
and I
seeing certain officials that certain
referees that I do think it's time that
they really consider retirement whether
it's voluntary or maybe mandatory but I
think based on how these young guys are
performing you know maybe it's time for
another set of new guys to occupy that
position okay and where's Edie these
days he's there I mean he's a consultant
now so he's making a stink in the rounds
talking about what roughing the passer
is I remember I remember him saying to
me before he left when I leave I'm not I
don't want anything to do with the NFL
I'm gonna get my motor home and drive
around the country and now I read about
him trying to defend the roughing the
passer calls as the league officiating
department consultant so he really
hasn't oh my gosh she's still in the
messes not gone away all right Mike I
appreciate the two sides let's chat
again soon thanks for the call thank you
you got that's Mike Pereira Fox Sports
that Mike Pereira the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience